[Music]
so physiology or the so-called
pseudoscience of leading character from
faces has a very very long history the
first historical document date all the
way back to the time of Aristotle but it
really got extremely extremely popular
in dating and 19th century and for a
while so there were quite a few studies
in the beginning of the 20th century we
are talking about twenties in the
thirties by psychologists finding very
very little evidence for the accuracy of
genomic inferences and recently there
was for example a computer science paper
claiming that presumably you can guess
whether a person is a criminal or not
based on their facial image and actually
the history of identifying the criminal
has a very very long history in
physiology there's lots of lots of
studies showing effects of appearance
across different domains in my own lab
more than 10 years ago we show that you
can predict electoral success based on
judgment from the appearance of
politicians then there have been many
other studies in the legal domain so for
example a recent studies show that
prisoners who are sentenced to death for
the same crime as those who were
sentenced to a life sentence without
parole
the main difference was the prisoners
were sentenced to death look less
trustworthy there's been a lot of
evidence in economic game so for example
economists love this sort of economic
games where we have any interactions and
if I don't know anything about you I
have a risky choice whether to invest in
you or not if I invest in you're
trustworthy then we are both better off
but if you entrust work you can take
away my money and run away so it's it
creates this risky situation and in many
studies suggests that in fact if we
think if the appearance of the other
person is untrustworthy we tend not to
invest in these people interestingly
there was a star
that was done in in Germany in
Switzerland when in fact people plate
anonymously and they also did different
measurements of the faces turns out the
dis measurements that are supposed to
predict untrustworthiness or
aggressiveness didn't predict at all how
how people will behave in this kind of a
anonymous economic game and the
interesting part is that these
participants they when some device for
accurate responses and so for every
accurate response they were supposed
essentially trying to predict what the
person did in the situation they ended
up losing money because they were
relying on this kind of appearance but
you can see how in a real-life situation
you can have all kinds of
self-fulfilling prophecies so we come
and play with you in a game I decided
for some reason that you are
untrustworthy
so my first move is not cooperative move
well you reciprocate in a similar way I
don't trust you so why would you trust
me and that kind of leads to a
self-fulfilling prophecy so you can
create these kinds of dynamic dynamic
inconsistency in the situation where in
fact the people could be perfectly trust
working might cooperate but the
appearance cues can get into the way now
to the extent that you agree in these
impressions an important empirical
question is well what is the way
disagreement coming from and so in the
past decades we have built mathematical
models and other groups have built their
own models that essentially are trying
to discover the queues the people are
using when they form these impressions
so what kinds of queues you can observe
well when you're designing whether
somebody's trust work you're not one of
the most important input is emotional
expressions so often in psychology we
talk about that there's emotional
neutral faces and there's faces
expressing different emotions but the
fact of the matter is that an emotional
neutral face is a fiction it's a
psychological fiction you could be
emotionally neutral by
you haven't been sleep deprived you look
better if you have a nice day you will
look better even if you are not smiling
so although the expressions might not be
explicit or exaggerated the way they
typically studied in studies and
emotional expressions there are subtle
expressions on our faces
so this expression is a very important
input to impressions notice they might
be accurate these impressions at the
particular moment here now but they
would be very lousy as a guide to what
the person is in general across timing
situations to get back to
trustworthiness phases that look like
they're smiling they have a positive
expressions they persist more positive
in faces that look this gruntled they
persist more negatively what are they
are the inputs many of the other inputs
come from stereotypes for example
feminine faces the perceived is more
trustworthy than masculine faces and the
other hand masculine faces are perceived
as more dominant so there are lots of
sand lots of cues and the accuse that
actually completely reducing critique to
others for example faces that resemble
people that you already like you would
tend to like not knowing anything about
these people and the other way around
faces that resemble people that you
dislike you will tend not to like
bearing no other information about these
people
[Music]